-Ricky, now you're known for
having strong opinions
about all different
kinds of things.
So with that in mind,
I want to play a game
of "Wheel of Opinions!"
-♪ Wheel of opinions ♪
-There you go.
-[ Laughs ] I love that.
Got a theme tune.
A lot of thought has gone
into the game.
-Here's how it works.
I'm gonna hit this button here,
which is bluetooth
attached to the studio,
and it's going to activate
the opinion topic generator.
And it's going to land
on a random topic.
-[ Laughs ]
-And whatever it is, you have to
give your opinion on it.
You ready for this?
-Yeah.
-Alright, here we go buddy.
[ Beeping ]
Horoscopes.
I like horoscopes.
-[ Groans ] Ridiculous.
-What?
-Nonsense.
-Why?
-A pseudoscience.
How can your horoscope,
how can people born
around the same time have all
the same characteristics?
If they were in people's minds,
because they --
First of all, they would make
them flattering, don't they?
They say things like oh, Cancer,
you're brave but considerate.
You know, Virgo, logical,
hard working.
Not one star sign says,
"You've got bad breath
and you're gullible."
You know?
Those daily things that are,
you know, predictions,
they're so vague.
It's all things like, "Today you
will seize an opportunity."
Well, what does that mean?
They've got
to say something like...
If it said, "Sally Marsden
in Teddington,
your boss is going to fire you
today because he knows
it was you that nicked
the petty cash,"
then I'd believe them.
But until then,
it's absolute nonsense.
[ Ding ]
-Let's hear another topic.
Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
-Made up nonsense.
-Weed gummies.
I don't think
you're a weed gummy guy.
-Well, I mean, I think
they're probably good
for weaning kids on to drugs.
-[ Laughs ]
No!
-If you're like,
"Little Tommy
won't smoke his joint."
Give him a weed gummy.
That will help.
[ Laughing ]
[ Ding ]
-Here we go, another topic.
[ Beeping ]
We're moving.
Alright, mechanical pencils.
When you click and the lead
comes, you know.
-Why?
What was up with the pencil?
What was wrong with the pencil?
Who is going these pencils,
they're not good anymore?
What was wrong with it?
This invention --
I remember when I worked
in an office,
it was a little arm
that went down when
you wanted a paper clip.
Like, people are going,
"I can't pick up
paper clips anymore.
Fingers are so passe.
I can't pick up paper."
It's been made up.
No one needed it.
What was wrong with a pencil?
Although I think that
about a lot of stuff,
like belt buckles now.
They're like trying to do
the Rubik's cube.
What was up with the belt?
And watch straps,
absolute nonsense.
It's fine.
I got a pair of trainers,
and it was ridiculous.
You had to pull open a thing,
then pull them up
and then pull a drawstring.
What was up with laces?
A pencil is fine.
No one's ever -- no one's ever
been disappointed with a pencil.
It's never -- it's never
been needed to be changed
-Well, imagine having --
Imagine having a pencil that...
-[ Laughs ]
-Some pencils have disappointed.
[ Ding ]
Let's just say.
Let's just move on.
Here we go, another one.
Last one, Ricky,
then I'll leave you alone.
Thank you so much for doing
this.
Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
This is -- I don't know
if we have time for this.
Space exploration.
-Ah, I mean, it depends for who.
I like the idea there's
a space program
and I love the feat
that we've been over.
Satellites and, you know,
Hubble telescope
and we put a man on the moon.
It's incredible.
It makes me laugh as well.
When you see members of like,
the human race taking credit
for things
that a few people did.
Like, suddenly these people go,
"We put a man on the moon."
I go, what do you mean we?
You live in a [bleep] bin.
You couldn't even point
to the moon,
so stop taking credit for things
the rest of mankind have done.
-You had nothing to do
with the moon landing.
-Yeah, you did nothing
And I think it's, you know,
it's great as a science program.
They're bringing in this thing
where I was offered
on one of these things to go in
space for 15 minutes,
and it was like a group
of like billionaires
and they offered me a chance
to be the first comedian
to do a stand-up show in space.
I went, no.
I'm not going to risk --
That's mad.
I'm careful crossing the road.
Also, these people that pay
like $300,000
to go in space
and have a look around.
They go, here's Ricky Gervais
doing 10 minutes.
they can watch me on YouTube
and now they've blown $300,000.
Look out the window.
That's the other thing.
People say let's go into space,
and you look up.
We're in space.
We're in space now.
We're right in the middle.
There's nothing you can see
that you can't see from here.
It's like me getting out
of the chair and going over
there and going,
I can see the chair from here.
You were in the chair.
There's nothing.
You're not going to find --
Well, we might find
a new planet.
Where is this planet?
It'll take you about 1,000 years
to get there.
What do they expect a find when
they freeze and they go there?
They expect to find this
an amazing race of things
that tells us all
the secrets of the universe
and it'll be big slug at that.
And you'll get there
and it's like -- You go,
Oh, is there -- how can we cure
everything?
And they go, "I don't know.
We're space --
we're space slugs.
We're absolute -- we're moronic.
So it won't be
what people think.
It will never be as good
as people think.
So just stay at home and watch
Netflix, "After Life."
-We're in -- we're in space.
-Yeah, we're right in the
[bleep] middle of it.
[ Ding ]
-[ Laughs ]
That's all the time we have
for "Wheel of Opinions!"
My thanks again
to Ricky Gervais.
You can watch his show
"After Life" on Netflix.
Oh, my gosh.
My face hurts yet again.
You've done it.
Ricky, thanks so much
for being here.
I needed a laugh.